all right melinda and lanayas
uh where do you guys grow up where are
you from originally
i grew up in glendora california i grew
up in covina california so suburbs of
l.a san gabriel valley
and uh melinda tell me about your
childhood
how'd you grow um spoiled rotten
um in a very nice home
fed religion my mom worked at our church
uh
presbyterian church for 30 years
so somewhat wealthy family yeah
yeah and you know my siblings were
10 12 and 14 years older than me so
it was like having five parents really
um
but a very close-knit family you know
they still get together
all the time every holiday birthday
stuff like that how would you describe
your childhood
i was happy you were having happy
spoiled i mean i got everything i wanted
great childhood but except what
except for when they decided to cut me
off and that was
a huge rude awakening but i am
so grateful that they did because um
had they not i would still be
not know the value of a dollar i would
there's a lot of life lessons
huge life lessons that i would um be
struggling with still today
if i hadn't if they hadn't i'm sorry
yeah
and ladies how'd you grow up um i never
met my dad
and my mom raised four kids by herself
and we were always on welfare and always
moving from place to place
like pretty much the opposite of the way
she grew up
because we were always like going
without
like food or electricity or like you
know
hot water like it was really rough
growing up for me
and my sisters like i have three sisters
and only boy
so i don't know it just seemed like
really hard for me growing up
like i didn't have like a really good
childhood
it's interesting that you guys are so
different the way you grew up
yeah i think i think sometimes he
resents me
for for how i grew up even though
when i look back at it i feel like it
was
it it was a big disservice my parents
did to me
as far as spoiling me and you know they
did it out of love
but uh it put me back
a little bit and i had to learn a lot
i think it's what made me defiant and
made me want to go
on the other side of those tracks and
find out
what was over there you know and i don't
know i just
there's a lot of things that
were negative that came from that but no
abuse no sexual abuse or
physical abuse or anything like that no
nothing like that
how far do you guys go in school okay
how far did you go to school
i've done well i did all my prereqs for
the rn program
and i've done a couple i cosmetology
and certified medical assistant
so i enjoy going to school um i mean all
the way to
11th grade or i
completed 11th grade and i never went to
senior year
so i still need my credits to graduate
high school because i
technically never graduated high school
got it
and drugs came into the picture for you
at what age
um that would be freshman year in high
school
uh for me it was
right around the same time period that
uh i dropped out of high school
yeah what are your drugs today
what drugs do we do today yes um
i do uh methamphetamines
heroin roxies
fentanyl but i don't do fentanyl anymore
um what else
oh i do everything like i've done
everything
i'm mean but what do you do today i
prefer uh
heroin and uh crystal meth and i slam
both of them
intravenously yeah and where do you guys
live now
we're homeless we're homeless on the
streets of where we grew up pretty much
you're not on skid row you're well i
lived nine months out here on skid row
and then um that kind of went bad so i
had to go back to staying out on the
streets where
i grew up when you say things went bad
like
i got into like a bad dope deal and uh
some guys trying to like stab me and
stuff
over um sand julian and uh
sixth i think right in in a porta potty
because like
i guess i owed this guy money and stuff
and yeah owing people money on skid rows
is a good way to get hurt
yeah and uh i luckily pushed one of them
up into the other one and escaped out of
the bathroom but there was three of them
and they had their knives out and stuff
and luckily i got away
because i don't know um
i left that day and i never came back so
i rarely come back out here to like pick
up drugs
like that's why we're out here right now
we're here today
i came out here because uh honestly we
sold some food stamps and uh she let me
borrow some money so i can
uh pick up what i needed and i just
spent a hundred dollars now i don't have
anything
and how do you guys support yourself now
well
now i recycle every day he recycles and
i help him
you know yeah i help him
um not every day but um
i i do also get as a signing disability
now back before i i relapsed
um i worked full-time and i
received that now i just receive it i
don't i don't work
i'm really trying to get back into
recovery i had eight and a half years
clean
so oh you did yeah do you have kids yes
they're grown yeah i have no kids no
kids
i mean what do you
tell me your your view on on this
lifestyle
and addiction and all that i mean it's
it's
my life i've heard it all i mean my
point
people say my point of view is um
i'm kind of glad it happened because um
now i know
in a way but but um
would i do it over again probably not
because
um i've seen a lot of bad things and
i've
done a lot of bad things that i would
never have done if it wasn't for
wanting the the heroine so bad that you
know like it
it takes away from like your values and
your morals
and it makes you like
not care about things that you really do
care about you know
and i've had a lot of people turn their
backs on me because
they they knew i had done heroin and
like
they just like stereotyped me as this
person that i wasn't you know
yeah i've heard many addicts say their
their priorities are so
changed because yeah i agree you know
their families their health their
yeah everything is is a distant
second to the fix i feel like my whole
demeanor is different
because of
the drugs that i continue
to do even though i knew like it wasn't
going to be like the first time
[Music]
what regrets do you guys have if any
what regrets me relapsing i knew
i knew that my misery was going to be
refunded to me almost immediately
and not only was it refunded to me like
times 10.
and i've experienced things and gone
through things
that no one most people don't and
that people should never have to go
through and
i chose that it's my fault like i get it
i take responsibility for that um
nevertheless that the hurt and the pain
from those things the repercussions from
those poor choices
um have really i mean some i can let go
or just kind of you know deal with and
then some
just they're always there and and it's
like kind of beat yourself up over
like what are you doing like what am i
doing yeah you had a career you were
successful you
exactly come from a good family exactly
what i mean what what do you think
was the mistake or what was the trauma
that you're
hiding from or or what was the mistake
you made or what
the mistake i made was i stopped working
a program
synonymous i stopped working a program
there are certain things that you should
you need when you get into uh recovery
uh there's certain things that you're to
do
in order to to keep that recovery i mean
you could want it
until you're blue in the face but if
you're not going to meetings if you're
not a service if you're not being
eventually being a sponsor yourself
there's there's like i said there's like
they call it your toolbox
if you're not keeping that maintained um
then you're gonna it's like how many
times can you walk by a barber shop and
then
not get a haircut you're gonna
eventually get a haircut
so um
yeah i stopped seeing a sponsor i think
for two and a half years before i
relapsed
and i i was working full-time i was
going to school full-time
i wasn't going to hardly any meetings
you know i just wasn't doing what i knew
it took to stay clean
and then i moved into a house
with a couple other addicts that were
still
clean one of them i guess was dabbling
again
and when i saw her coming in and out
having fun doing that i was
you know you start making all those
rationalizations and justifications and
oh it'll be okay just one time no
but when time too many or thousands
never enough
anyway it's not worth it
it's not worth it i don't care who you
are it's not worth it
i regret not um i mean
i regret um showing people um
what it was like and they call it
turning somebody out
and i've turned people out and some of
the people that have turned out aren't
even alive anymore
turning them out is turning them onto
drugs yeah turn them on your heroine
because like i have a friend that just
passed away and i
pretty much turned him out on her own do
you feel
responsible for that yeah you know what
i do yeah
and it's not easy to live with stuff
like that because
he was a good friend you know
[Music]
you just it's hard sometimes what do you
think is the most misunderstood thing
about
addiction the people like
are stereotyped a certain way like like
that person don't
leave them around your wallet or or like
you can't leave them alone with this or
that
but it's not like that because i'm not
like that i don't steal
don't ever steal yeah i found the the
homeless people that are
recycling tend to be the most
upstanding trustworthy yeah because they
have an honest hustle
yeah yeah they don't steal their
recycling
you're not selling yourself you're not
exactly it's the most honest way to make
money
legitly you know like legally
and that's what i do every day i
if to answer that question i i think the
most
um misunderstood thing yes
is that it's a disease addiction is
is a disease it's an actual disease and
it's centered in the very
center of our brains and um you know
my parents i was clean like i said eight
and a half years
eight years um in all those eight years
my parents or family members
never went to like narconon or any of
those things and they they weren't
educated and then this time around
during this relapse they started seeing
going to those meetings
and with edu like them being educated
about
the disease of addiction it is
amazing how much
um better well how
how do i say this our relationship
is changed dramatically for the better
oh my gosh
and and yes they're still worried yes
they want me to get clean and sober
again
um but they're understanding that
it's not just me going out there and
saying you know
excuse my language [ __ ] you parents or
[ __ ] you family
um i don't give a [ __ ] what you say i'm
just gonna do what i want
it's not that it's really and especially
with heroin rather than methamphetamines
i use methamphetamines up until i met
him
but um anyways it it's
it's uh it's improved our relationships
amazingly and um thank god for those
those type of meetings for family
members and friends
yeah i think understanding yes amongst
everyone not just the addicts but the
families and everyone
right can help a lot yeah
because i mean even i used to just
think that all these homeless people
were just a bunch of lazy
right yeah no good you know
some of them are yeah yeah but not all
of them
yeah there's there's all kinds of
because they've just given up
you know they just give them up but the
stories of
childhood trauma that you'll hear they
always play affectionately
i feel like it's incredible how many
how common it is i that's probably the
that's probably the link right there or
the missing piece or whatever
what the what they go through in your
childhood
but i didn't go through me yeah you
didn't melanie's story is very
interesting because she's
coming from a pretty
trauma-free yeah childhood like major
trauma-free
was there addiction in your life was it
in my life yeah do you have any
relatives that are
i think my grandpa was an alcoholic but
i was never really around
i never saw him i think my well i know
for a fact that
my mother's father was a really bad
alcoholic but he died when i was seven
so
and i never experienced like an episode
or
any anything with him being drunk
other than that no
i guess that doesn't make any sense
maybe i'm just natural born
addict maybe you have a curious mind and
you're just curious
oh gosh i was a curious cat when i was
young yes yes
yes but i think um also
the other thing was is that i was just
bored
like i always wanted to hang out with
the bad kids
i always thought they were funner and
because it i they group differently and
they
i don't know i don't know
you guys been together how long four
years four years
it's hard to keep a relationship
together oh yeah on the streets
especially
yeah and being addicted yeah
trust that i think if i wasn't 10 years
older we would have broken up a long
time ago
because then i'm older i'm able to kind
of like see when things are just it's
his age
and i probably shouldn't just say oh yes
okay because
there there are things that need to be
he's gonna have to face them
we don't need to talk about that
understood
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your lives
that family is is number one and um
and that honestly i wish i had never
messed around with drugs um
because it's caused me nothing but
negativity
i've had to go through things you know
from getting my face split open for no
reason
um just to knowing people that have been
through some
crazy things i i just it's all stuff
that no one needs to
ever know or go through and
that i should have listened to my
parents i should have listened to them
the one lesson that i learned was
um you never know what you have until
it's gone so don't wait till it's fun to
appreciate what you have
yeah those are good lessons
all right i should have listened more
than always ran my mouth
that's for sure thank you so much for
sharing your stories thank you
thank you okay
you